the coronavirus pandemic has been
devastating
scary and long it's also been very
revealing about the two different
americas we all live in
for example america's billionaires
increased their wealth by
over one trillion with a t dollar since
the pandemic began
meanwhile over 40 percent of black owned
businesses
closed their doors forever between last
february and april
for white owned businesses the number
was just 17 percent
that's according to a study from the
university of california
but black owned businesses can be saved
if people
shop at them a survey from the black
chamber of commerce showed nearly 75
percent of black owned businesses
saw customers rise in the two months
following george floyd's murder
but since then they have returned to
their pre-covered rates
that's why my next guest is launching
the black businesses matter
matching fund using the power of the
internet and leveraging the success
of corporations to get dollars to small
businesses
joining me now is marcus samuelson
award-winning chef
and author his latest book is the rise
black cooks and the soul of american
food
which i probably should read because i
can't cook at all marcus it's the thing
um i'm not good at it uh so maybe we'll
we'll talk offline
um and you can give me some tips um i'm
here for you
i can help you cook anytime and so can
many black chefs around the country
especially personal chef that would be
happy
to give you some cooking classes
please help me i i feel like you know
i'm
the shame of my family because my mom is
an excellent cook she taught us
she spent time my sister she
internalized it she remembers
i do not and i also like i don't enjoy
it so i'm trying to find
i'm trying to find an interest in it but
let's talk about the black businesses
matter matching fund
how does it all work and how did it come
about
well it came about you know i live in
harlem and my business is in harlem and
also have a restaurant in
overtown in miami so a lot of my work is
and my partner's work
are focusing african-american black and
brown communities
and when you see first hand how
covet has impacted black and brown
businesses you have to do something
you know and it's going to take um we
need local government we need federal
government
but we also need private partnership
with uh
businesses that are thriving so um you
know
we very fortunate to partner with
ubereats
to create this you know black owned
businesses don't need more
uh loans no more debt we need grants
uh to survive so together with ubereats
we created
uh black business matters matching fund
where we give out grants to um
black owned restaurants all over the
country
and every time you buy a meal
or from a black business from a black
restaurant ubereats will match that with
one dollar
and you know we want to raise a lot of
money and awareness for that and we're
going to give the money right back out
to black owned restaurants
so that sounds amazing because i feel
like over the summer
when all the protests started and
everybody was trying to get woke and
they were reading books about
anti-racism
and they were like what can i do better
they were actually
shopping at black businesses because
that was one of the things activists
were saying
this is how you could tangibly help the
black community
uh versus just posting things on your
instagram you can actually give money to
black owned businesses
but then that stopped how do we get that
momentum
back um you know it feels like it's not
like racial justice is an issue
that's over it's not solved no but we we
do need
a high awareness of it and you know
black history month does
help bring awareness to that but then
for us as you know in our communities
this is not something that you need a
month's attention on
you know it will take i believe during
and post code but it will take
probably our communities five to seven
years to go back to pre-covet
you know and most businesses black home
business doesn't have that
great they don't have that amount of
stamina or financial stamina so they
they just like you saw before 41 of
black owned businesses
has already closed in the hospitality
businesses
we live check to check we live
it's almost like a family business that
lived like week to week
check back to check restaurant industry
has to roll normally to seven percent
profit margin right
and you think that in terms of the black
content that means we don't have enough
money saved up to navigate through that
so we need real help
we need real partnership between
corporations between local
government and federal government and
that's what i'm so proud to bring
with my partners you know black business
matters matching fund that
all corporations and individuals can
help out so we can give
black businesses some relief
one of the things that you've done
marcus is you make sure your restaurants
are in the community so i
i used to live in harlem i moved to
brooklyn subsequently but
um one of the things that you know you
open your businesses in the heart
of the black community why is that so
important because you've done that in
numerous cities around the country
yeah newark over town in miami and here
in harlem well
you know i'm the intersection of of you
know being black but also being an
immigrant
right so it's important for me to give
back to the communities that have been
treated me and my family as well but it
also is about job creation when you
create
a restaurant like red rooster it creates
about 150 jobs that are in those
communities and of those communities
why should our dreams and our
opportunities always be outside our
communities
so that that's why it's so important it
also
creates a different influx when you have
a restaurant like red rooster
a third of our guests are from harlem
the two-thirds come outside and it means
that they can interact in our
communities and spend money in our
communities
and that's equally important especially
in times like this
that's so important i mean that was one
of the i mean red rooster was pretty
popping
when i lived when i lived in harlem for
sure it is a popular destination for
tourists for people who live in harlem
as you said um so
what are you going to teach me how to
cook because i feel like i need to start
simple
what's the easiest thing to start with
well the next time we do this segment
we can do it social distance in the
studio or you can jump on one of my zoom
classes
and and then i can teach you how to cook
but you know it is
uh it's all about you know doing food
that you love to eat and simplify it
right if you like
fish start with a grilled piece of
salmon add some greens into that
fold in something like a simple couscous
and you got a meal
under 15 minutes and listen to your
sister oh i'm into that and i like
couscous
i like who's good oh i'm going to listen
to her but i'm also going to listen to
you marcus
and hopefully i'll be able to join one
of the zooms soon um
because i really do like to eat so it's
a shame that i'm not able to cook better
uh marcus samuelson thank you so much
for being here um and for all that you
do in the community of harlem and and
newark and also in miami
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching